hey guys I'm Kiernan Shipka I'm over
here at BuzzFeed today and I'm going to
be taking the witch chilling Adventures
of Sabrina character are you quiz I'm
feeling excited I mean taking a BuzzFeed
quiz is pretty much me and my natural
habitat so I'm feeling pretty ready and
also pretty curious as to which
character I get pick a sense sight touch
taste sound smell or the sixth sense oh
man I mean it's it's tough and I always
overthink a BuzzFeed quiz to be quite
honest but I'm gonna go with the sixth
sense just because it's cool and it's
witchy pick a Riverdale character to
hang with Cheryl Polly
Archie tawny Alice or Kevin Kevin Keller
is obviously the person you want to hang
out with I mean they're all great
characters but like Kevin's Kevin's the
best day of choice what's your worst
trait you keep a lot of secrets from
your friends you don't leave the house
enough you're loving but not exactly
warm you can be a little two-faced you
don't stand up for yourself or you scare
too easily I'm gonna go with you don't
leave the house enough because I
actually have been getting so much
better at this I think so much better at
like going out and really live in my
best life but I am a grandma at heart
no shame in my game I love a good night
I've just you know really cozying up and
having a wild night with Netflix and a
BuzzFeed quiz or to choose a pop-culture
cat as you're familiar Thackery Binx
from hocus-pocus smelly cat from friends
Simba from Lion King grumpy cat Garfield
or Hello Kitty this is a tough one
because growing up I was very obsessed
with Hello Kitty like to the point where
I had a you know Halle Hello Kitty
wallet until I was like 14 years old and
my dog ate it
but the attitude that grumpy cat is
giving me right now is so undeniable and
so just like alluring I'm so into it so
I have to pick grumpy cat because
usually like staring into my soul and
there's I feel like I don't have a
choice alright you can cast one spell
what's it going to be love spell a hex
on your enemy resurrection spell money
spell protection spell or healing spell
I'm all about the healing vibes
I would love to place a
he's built on my grandma hip flexers
that would be great
finally what's your favorite Halloween
candy Reese's Pieces Sour Patch Kids
candy corn candy eyeballs dark chocolate
Kit Kats or Twizzlers candy corn I'm not
even gonna put my plunge myself into the
debate because like I said I'm
completely neutral but like I'm just not
gonna go there I'm more of a chocolate
person so we we come to Reese's Pieces
and that's that's what I decide and I'm
very confident in my decision and I'm
Rosalind Walker it says I'm a totally
empowered badass babe who who speaks out
in the face of injustice but you're also
kind of going through a lot right now
like Rosalind you'll power through it
and come out even stronger than you
thought possible I love that I feel so
honored because she's a really badass
cool character and so I'm like happy I'm
not madam Satan let's just say about
much this is cool this is good you know
when I was growing up when I was like 12
13 whatever I watched I wanted to be and
live it was really heartbreaking when
like I couldn't be Blair Waldorf you
know but like I feel like young girls to
certain extent are gonna be like
inspired and empowered by Sabrina and I
think that's really cool too thanks guys
so much for tuning in you can catch the
chilling Adventures of Sabrina on
Netflix right after October 26 the first
10 episodes drop thanks for tuning in
see you later the bite
[Music]